the walking-dead saw some drastic
changes during its ninth season raising
countless questions about season 10 with
the season premiere arriving soon we've
gone ahead and pulled together
everything you need to know heading into
the 10th year of the dramatic complex
gruesome zombie madness for those
wondering what the Walking Dead has in
store for its 10th season an extensive
trailer was released at comic-con in
july 2019 one of the primary themes of
the trailer was fear not of the undead
but rather of the very much alive alpha
and her army of whisperers both of which
featured predominantly throughout season
9 the animalistic villains appeared to
be a central part of the new season and
could lead to an all-out war at some
point down the road before we dive into
any new additions to the cast it's worth
taking a quick trip down memory lane to
remember the primary characters that the
show lost then the catastrophic Levi's
late chorus of season 9 Rick Grimes may
not be dead but he disappeared early on
after he successfully blew up the bridge
to stop a horde of zombies from gaining
access on top of that there was the
mysterious disappearance of Mac Erie
adding to the list we also have Jesus
who was killed off in the fading moments
of the midseason finale and finally
their season 9s penultimate episode
which ended with 10 heads on pikes on
alphas creepy new border wall including
Tara Henry Tammy and Enid's
season 9 of The Walking Dead was
highlighted by the departure of major
cast members like Andrew Lincoln and
lauren cohan and it turned out that that
was just the beginning
months before season 10 premiere it was
already a well established back that
Danai gurira
who plays The Fearless Michonne would be
leaving the show at some point during
the upcoming season at this point
reports seem to indicate that Michonne
will be present throughout most of the
season which should give us plenty of
time to prepare for her exit there are
only two main characters not counting
Rick who have made it from the dark days
of season 1 all the way to the decade
mark Daryl and Carol season 9 had a
massive six year time jump that
drastically changed the status quo for
both characters post time jump Daryl was
seen living off on his own
what Queen Carol had married King
Ezekiel and adopted Henry as her son by
the end of the season daryl is drawn out
of seclusion and back into the
unraveling events with the whispers and
Carol loses Henry breaks up with Ezekiel
and advocates her crown the season 10
trailer seems to promise even more
changes for the longtime fan favorite
characters season 9 had plenty of
different plot lines to follow but one
that stood out from the bunch was the
interesting parallel
between carol and alpha the two mothers
have been to hell and back again ever
since the apocalypse hit both are
powerful indomitable characters but
they've developed dramatically different
philosophies about post-apocalyptic life
this was already interesting to watch as
their children met and became infatuated
with each other on the one hand alpha
watched as her daughter was converted
from the whisper aways and ultimately
taken under Carol's wing on the other
Carol faced Rama yet again when her
adopted son Henry was abducted by alpha
and then decapitated for her gruesome
border wall all of these similarities
and grievances set the pair up for an
epic showdown and it appears that season
10 is where that clash of wills is going
to take place actress Melissa McBride
has already declared that she thinks
there should be a confrontation telling
the Hall H audience at San Diego Comic
Con that I feel like there deserves to
be one Carol wants vengeance on top of
that showrunner Angela Kang has also
expressed excitement for the two women
to clash adding that they're both two
incredibly powerful women who just
happened to be on opposite sides of this
kind of epic struggle that is happening
between our people and the whisperers so
there's just some really cool stuff up
ahead season 10 looks to promise plenty
of problems for the heroes of The
Walking Dead in fact there are not one
not two but three primary villains
already in the cards first off there's
negan season 9 revealed a character that
was both humbled and even a bit too
Rohit season 10 promises to continue the
conflicted characters storylines with
showrunner Kang confirming that he'll be
released from prison on the talking dead
she said negan is a guy who likes to be
in the middle of things and you know
being in a jail cell means he's
definitely not in the middle of things
negan drama aside the show also has to
deal with the new baddie on the block
alpha the horrifyingly calm leader of
the whisperers showed her villainous
chops throughout the previous year
on top of alpha and her muscle-bound
sidekick beta the new season is also set
to debut gamma a whisper who is ultra
loyal to alpha and her agenda along with
a host of other changes season 9 showed
that weather can play a serious role in
the walking dead storyline the season
finale revealed a picturesque winter
landscape dotted with rotting bodies and
shuffling corpses Aldwych provided some
chilly new territory for the serial
thriller hey
[Music]
the change in scenery was a fun twist to
the shows typically hot southern setting
and the good news is it's not the last
we'll see of environmental changes
showrunner Angela Kang told
Entertainment Weekly that we're still
exploring other kinds of environmental
obstacles that we haven't done it seen
before so there will be some other new
stuff to look out for the promotional
material has already hinted at a couple
of new natural phenomena with one scene
showing what appears to be some
characters in front of a forest fire
oceanside in its waterfront location
also seem likely to factor into the new
season opening up the doors to some
aquatic adventures something that the
Walking Dead sisters show fear The
Walking Dead already explored in its
second season the massive six year leaf
in season nine had far-reaching
repercussions it introduced the
mysterious issue of Michonne and Daryl
scars aged Judith Grimes into a force to
be reckoned with surprised everyone with
her little brother and saw a growing
divide among the communities with all of
the shifting around one would think the
show would settle down to a regularly
paced timeline at some points but that's
not happening yet an AMC isn't even
trying to make it a surprise this time
season 9 ended with a jump forward into
the winter
now season 10 is poised to start with
yet another jump months ahead into the
following spring while the constant
shifts are a bit jarring it does
accelerate the age of the younger
generation this good serve is a perfect
catalyst to eventually tie in with the
second spin-off series which will be set
far in the future and follow the lives
of the first generation of humans to
grow up in the post-apocalyptic world as
you probably recall season 9 saw Rick
Grimes removed from the flagship Walking
Dead series but not killed off instead
the intrepid hero found himself washed
downstream along with a host of walkers
only to be picked up by a mysterious
helicopter and flown off since then the
question of what happened to Rick has
come up over and over again
Michonne was still struggling with the
loss six years later and Daryl seemed
ready to head off into the sunset
looking for his friend at any moment the
hints are likely to continue coming in
season 10 as the world gears up for the
planned Rick Grimes trio of films this
is especially likely since the hero
storyline has even been spilling over
into the spin-off series fear The
Walking Dead where what looked to be the
same helicopter was spotted in one
episode whatever the time in place it's
certain that the Rick Grimes saga will
continue at some point whether it ever
crosses back into the flagship series or
not though that isn't stopping the hint
happy production team from Pennsylvania
more clues about the hero's whereabouts
while the situation remains steeped in
mystery there is one meeting we can hope
to see once again we're talking about a
reunion between Rick and Daryl the two
brothers and arms shared a very
emotional last few episodes together
spent tussling trapped in a pits and
finally making up brother take my hand
the connection between the two
characters is tried-and-true and the
possibility of their finally finding
their way back to one another again is
certainly in the cards at this point in
an interview at San Diego comic-con
forum of The Walking Dead showrunner
Scott Gimple was asked if Daryl would
ever see Rick again he responded by
saying I can't rule that out have you
ever seen a little film When Harry Met
Sally that's how they're going to rejoin
again in related news there's also the
juicy potential for season 10 to feature
the return of absentee hilltop commander
Maggie actress Loren Cohen's brief
excursion to her own show on ABC looks
like it may end with a quick round trip
right back into the arms of the undead
while the failure of Cohen's new show to
get off the ground isn't necessarily
enough of a reason to assume that the
fan favorite actress will return there's
reason to hope Angela Kang went right
ahead and poured fuel on the fire by
making it clear that they're doing their
best to make her return a reality she
told DW that I'm not sure if I can say
much about it right now actually I'll
just say that we're working on it
clearly they haven't given up on
reintegrating Maggie back into the story
like Rick she was never killed off in
fact she was referenced multiple times
throughout season 9 and appeared to be
off on other business in an undisclosed
location if that's not enough potential
material for season 10 seems to be
hinting to a return appearance one sneak
peek shown on the talking dead directly
references letters from Maggie oh then
we sailed down south to his dock where
Oceanside has been picking up letters
from Maggie was anything there whatever
the show hasn't sought for Cohen's
character it hardly seems like she's
going to shuffle off this mortal coil
anytime soon
another factor to keep in mind going
into the 10th season is the soon to be
lack of source material for the show to
follow there's no doubt that the
on-screen version of The Walking Dead
has already charted of course all its
own the comics have always served as a
grounding point from which the show
could draw inspiration characters and
storylines but the truth is the show
runners have never shied away from
altering things as they go along
Carl's death Michonne and Rick's
relationship chains extended lifespan
the very existence of Daryl were all
cinematic alterations that don't have
their origins in print that said one
question worth asking is how things
would look if there was no source
material at all the answer may be
forthcoming sooner than expected just
months before the season 10 release date
The Walking Dead co creator Robert
Kirkman shocked fans with a
one-two punch that no one saw coming in
the comic series spoilers incoming first
he's suddenly and unexpectedly killed
off Rick Grimes then he followed it up
with the final installment and the
announcement that the comic book series
was officially over with his sudden
imposition of a hard ending to the
source material it will be interesting
to see how AMC handles their 10-year TWD
universe plans we'll just have to see
what that looks like when the new season
arrives on October 6 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff or coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]